I am the red white and blue pancakes
from Denny's murica and this is simply
bribery
I told me not to trust anyone this is
how it ends
everything goes Captain America is back
and he's fighting the Winter Soldier but
this time he has help from the Black
Widow Nick Fury and a whole bunch of
other cool characters in Captain America
the Winter Soldier that's pretty much
all we could say until we get the
spoiler territory like the Boyle corner
phrase to be much bigger this movie's
loaded
yeah it's like the anti Iron Man tube
where nothing has been in that movie
everything happens in this film uh so
like I said the spoiler corner this
might be longer but the only other thing
we can say honestly in terms of story is
that he is going after the Winter
Soldier uh identity is a mystery and
that shield is also after a shield is
the agency they work for they have a
popular ABC show I know it's it's more
like he's after shield well I'm a to
thing but after each other uh it's
complicated yeah so uh for now that's
about all we can reveal um and for me
watching this movie I'm I'm a huge
Captain America guy who's always got one
of my least favorites but I like the
first movie like we should prep talk
about that like the first movie find it
wasn't a big or grander they but they it
was fine for something I don't usually
get into with this character I'm like I
feels great I like the the main guy and
rents going all that stuff uh but I
think a lot of it sir just like filler
until the Avengers and in a sense
watching this one if I disagree
you like the captain yeah because I
don't feel it was filler because it was
an origin story that needed to be told
so to me it's like saying well I think
the first Batman II gives us filler
really until you get too dark and I
didn't know you could kind of make that
argument
it's not what you needed to set up the
character so I don't think it was filler
I don't think it was a great great movie
I thought it was pretty darn good though
like I I've always been a Captain
America fan um when it comes to the
Avengers I was always our man than
Captain America so Thor was way down at
the bottom which is why I'm still amazed
we got to Thor movies about whatever so
I thought the film actually did a pretty
good job and it was really like old
school in a fun way
yeah it's it you don't get that any but
the guy who directed it I believe also
director Rocketeer anything my but I
like that and I was very stuck in the
40s the Red Skull Hugo Weaving his red
skull was great it was very colorful
it just it's exactly what Captain
America needed to be not not the
greatest comic book movie ever but it
really did its job it was a
straightforward comic book movie you
watch it so it's that's what is one of
the things like that far pass the origin
of Captain America there you go yeah um
and now we have this one this takes
place in modern time so you don't quite
have like you're talking about sort of
the upbeat feel of the 40s and stuff and
sort of the style life look now it it's
modern so you can't wondering what
they're gonna do uh and with this one I
got you know a touch of the filler vibe
but you know and I did see is quite
grandeur epic but for a just a good
action film at just superheroes comic
books kind of twists and turns and good
characters and a decent action I liked
it I thought it was relatively strong uh
I couldn't disagree with that statement
more about not really that epic this is
probably the most epic comic book movie
we've had since probably well on the
Marvel Universe at least sense Avengers
I mean Thor 2 Iron Man 3 oh no I I agree
but I think okay liquid this way when I
think of like epic comic book movie I
think of like you know yeah Batman even
Avengers uh the EVAs of the Spider Man
this goes toe-to-toe with that easily
yeah I think so
yeah absolutely I mean for me I
definitely saw there's it definitely
stepped up its game from the last one I
mean this definitely seems like much
bigger but it's still a it's fill to be
continued and even
the last image before the credits is
sort of like here we go it's not good
like anything that grand or big um but
at the same time for something that is
like think about what happened on this
part of the problem you're probably just
gonna have to turn into the spoiler
corner because but when you think about
what happened Bob isn't Luigi yeah it's
incredibly epic well no it won't say the
student now I'll say this too uh after I
saw the movie I'm like you know that
Bella's got even barely expected it all
right and as I let it sit with me I
realize man there's a lot of areas they
could have gone wrong and there's a lot
of areas where I'm like well in another
movie they would have done this one
another movie they will have done this
collision another movie and it's like
they definitely have some of those
caches but thinking back it's like this
could have been just callek we you said
like up for to or an Ironman to rebe or
something but it it actually does kind
of stand basically what it did was it
gave me my Superman movie one year later
this is what's this is what Man of Steel
should have been like it's an American
icon dealing with darkness going through
a personal journey like trying to figure
out where he stands in the world now I'm
like and it did it right and it was
really fun and it was executed well and
the flash beds made sense the the whole
thing is just DC take notes take notes
you wanna know what I'll let you all
know my favorite scene in this movie and
Warner Brothers take notes to the lot of
you you wanna my favorite scene in this
movie is uh it's not after pay it's not
anything it's the very opening where you
see uh you see Captain America jog a
drive with this other guy a guy who's
got to be a main character but you don't
even know he could just be a guy and
they just here left ya on your left I
mean and it's just a nice conversation
they just talk they share some war
stories they make some jokes and they're
people holy crap you can hear that today
and it's not like let me tell you about
my dark torrid tormented paz' know
they're shooting the shit they're the
enemy of religion Jesus had a go at you
I am captain Jesus like
none of that crap well and and that all
comes back as well because we do see
that guy again and when they get back
together to team up uh you're really
happy to see it because you're like well
you know they have like a real good
connection and you genuinely want to see
them work together and they do work
together and the guy is great uh this
Falcon guy who I also get I know nothing
about Malkin what else can I do nothing
about who Falcon was I don't look him up
afterwards I'm like oh he's a couple
characters with kept America okay but
he's awesome I want more of those guy
best knew how would you say it
techno gadget things since Iron Man yeah
I mean I'd actually love to see him go
toe-to-toe with Iron Man actually no
yeah well especially after you see the
comic of what he looks like it's like oh
no this is a good upgrade upgrade I was
so impressed with what they did with
Falcon and every single character in
this movie has a point
and I was like avoiding and they're
Piatt and like I said those people you
feel like they're people while you can
relate to them you can talk with it you
get an idea if you talk to Nick Fury
what he would say bang via conversation
if you talk to Black Widow what she
would say back if you had a conversation
within the relationship she has with
Captain America like this actually ended
up being a really great black with a
movie who has been criminally under
games I'm gonna say right now Black
Widow
I think is my new favorite Avenger
because it used to be like maybe Iron
Man and acted I kind of like the guy
played for I think she Toby's way up
there but but like and I think so much
of it I Knight again necessarily printed
the writing I really do think it's
Scarlett Johansson she brings this
attitude and this presence to her that
the odds of the closest analogy I can
think of I think Indiana Jones like just
the waist like yeah just do it her okay
it's Meghan it's the cynicism in this
monotone some of it things really work
I'm gonna choose the writing though
because the concept of putting the Boy
Scout with the sort of mean girl oh I
don't think they're so diametrically
opposed that she doesn't know she
doesn't seem me to meet you just mean
girl
do what you gotta be a naughty one i
mean basically this is like the femme
fatale being said against the Boy Scout
like it just it actually really works
together but not in a gimmicky but yeah
I'm gonna give you like they really want
well Beecher and and I like this movie
too because uh you have all these
pairings of you got kept America with
Falcon you have him with Black Widow
yeah but with Nick Fury you and they'll
work yeah they all legitimately work
every you know it's a surprisingly the
only character that is slightly wasted
was the winter so Fisher yeah we didn't
feel like I feel like they're once again
pulling the old Marvel trick and they
actually won't DC that they all do it of
like oh we can't give away the entire
story now because then we won't have
something for a third film and well
that's our my phone with my I say it
feels a little bit like the filler like
I've got you know what what Batman it's
like it's done
yeah but the actual plot that happens
doesn't his character is a little filler
Asian that they could have fleshed out
more with him but I got just enough that
I felt satisfied oh no I totally did too
um especially going to it so like it's
no Mandarin like if you're worried about
it's like oh my god that's good turn
into Mandarin like it's not bad no it's
not they do they just give him
development but it's all kind of
squeezed in at the end and I'm sort of
thinking like will this be more
interesting if it was spread out through
the whole well it feels like it should
have been more of the focus hmm and
instead before the focus is more about
the political intrigue the Captain
America wrestling with what America
means now to him and this and that which
is fine but it gets a little bit crowded
like yeah the two things you mentioned
one the Winter Soldier not getting quite
enough focus uh the only other thing
I'll bring up that kind of bothered me
was that uh the climax particularly
while impressive and you see the money
up there looks so cool yeah you know we
can wrap this up a little earlier
such a problem with modern films nobody
remembers how to make a 90 minute movie
nobody you remember like all the films
we watch in the 80s and we watch and now
we're like wow that's really short that
used to be normal
well I and it worked that way because
it's economy of storytelling and
nowadays this is my one gripe with this
film too it's like I feel like they're
telling like this two and a half hours
story that you know could have been done
in 90 minutes honestly I wasn't feeling
like it was I wasn't feeling like it was
long until we got to the climax I was
actually with it throughout majority of
it but I think there's one point where
like Falcon is fighting like this other
dude this white dude coming up the
stairs he's like I got him he lost his
wings I've ever thinking like you know
dude you don't have your wings you got
your time on the sky you're you're good
we can edit this out and oh yes there's
a little fight sequence going on as well
you didn't need that and it's the fact
that it's not that he just goes back in
there to restart the fight I'm like okay
so they doesn't want to go out like a
bitch I get it but that fight itself
went on so long that like seriously like
the stuff with Captain America and black
wooden like their whole end of the fight
like against the main villains ends in
an invisible so if I kill and I yeah are
you guys still going you realize
everyone else is done yeah so it it was
a little long now to be fair it was
really good action set piece so it it's
not a Michael Bay film it's you know not
it's not bad it's just I feel like man
at some point we can cut these films
down to a more reasonable running - yeah
it's not an or Verbinski film owner it's
at World's End but for example for
example there's a scene early on where
Nick Fury is quartered by these cars and
it's a really cool scene Boston's badass
but but you could have cut it in half
really think about it I mean there's a
party he's cornered and they're giving
em and he's trying to find out but for
what the movie had to do he then escapes
and then they have a drive down the road
as I you didn't the drive down the road
just get to the ending of that and it
it's cool don't get me wrong it's all
very impressive because it's not God
awfully long
yes that slight amount of long we're
like wow this came really close to being
perfectly paced and then there's like an
extra five minutes here there and you're
like huh like but guys it's kind of an
epic honestly yeah my only other nitpick
is um the actions really sporadic some
of it is really good like probably some
of the best action you will see in a
comic book movie I'll dig in the shield
at this this decade yeah they made this
shield look realistic I'm like okay I
totally buy that this is a weapon now so
some of its really amazing and then some
of it is like that fucking Bourne
Identity crap there's like him yeah it's
that between Michael Bay and the board
the the Jason Bourne movies those have
seriously ruined action films for me
more than anything in the past ten years
like seriously you have all of this
technology you have CGI you have all of
this fight choreography yeah good good
show it and show it you got shaking the
camera you can see it it's for anyone
that's gonna be scared off by that it's
not the entire copy and it and the
enemies I would say it's half but it's
just enough where you're gonna have like
yeah okay I can make that out but you
didn't it's just enough where I'm able
to see just barely enough to be like wow
that looks like a really cool fight wish
I could have seen all of it like it is
so like in the cameras like I'm like I
thought I saw something really cool not
entirely sure but the thing is this film
at least does it way better than like a
Michael Bay movie or Heather's as its
your game yeah the first Hunger Games so
like it it's still like steps above but
it still has that one little thing that
bugs me which is like just just let us
see the action yeah and I know it's like
you want to show you to make it look a
little bit more realistic like you're in
there and stuff like that but not to be
that much yeah I feels like just a
little bit of shaking you know I'm gonna
for action for me I I honestly think is
the best movie probably since the Dark
Knight like when it comes to the action
and seven I'm not you know more that
ventures I'm not dissing Avengers
Avengers was very much it's hard to
explain there's a ton of CGI in this
movie as well and the vengers was very
good and I thought what they setup was
great you're still fighting a person
though not these giant oh yeah it's
generally this done old school oh
there's a ton of CGI in this very well
done for the most part there's only a
few things are Mike that's really fake
but the helicarrier's when they launch
like amazing there's there's just
something about like two dudes fighting
that I kind of missed to some extent I
mean they've been like in that Superman
I was like it's different they're flying
and that was just punch fly a million
miles away pond obviously covered by
green screen throughout the whole thing
here it's why this one looks and feels
like the Dark Knight did words Batman
with his fists flying in and kicking ass
and yeah the opening he's on a pony
you're like you know they didn't
green-screen the boat or you know he's
fighting this guy in the open e way puts
the she of that you know they didn't
green-screen all this they're really
they're they're really fighting for me
best best action since Dark Knight the
only thing it's missing the one thing
that Dark Knight does trumpet little is
there is a lot of CGI and there's never
a moment like I give Nolan all this
credit when stuff blew up particularly
in Dark Knight he tried to film as much
as that as he could without CGI again
they frickin flipped an entire truck on
LaSalle Street in Chicago if you've ever
been on LaSalle Street in Chicago you
realize what a nightmare that is to do
they really had that Chase on lower
Wacker and there's no big set piece like
that that feels a hundred percent real
there's a lot of giant CGI helicarrier's
and stuff so I kind of missed that a bit
but really just I've ever any more
though yeah yeah big and stuff I mean
but but it's really just increment no
what you tell me you're the critic I
don't know I was just blown away by this
movie somebody was asking me is it
better than Avengers and that what do
you think they seem like to they are
similar but they are still different
ventures is very much a fun knocking
Sock'em kind of action comedy am i
autumn on the grandest job and I even
get a degree I thought this is much more
hey let's really look at a character
look at what it means to be here it felt
like one superhero
journey surrounded by
good supporting cast that you like to
see where the other one Avengers it's
amazing it turned out as it did but it's
like we got five or six superheroes here
that you can't have that kind of movie
with that said well I told the the
people that were asking I guess better
I'm like it's pick your own poison
because you're completely right Avengers
was insanely entertaining really very
funny and I enjoyed it a lot
it's kind of shallow though like it's
really just a bunch of dudes hanging out
kicking little ass and this one not
really is funny well and it's it but
it's gotten to be much more yeah and I'm
not saying that's something that makes
the Avengers bad I thought it was a lot
of fun this one for me I kind of liked a
little more because I thought it had a
much stronger story a lot more depth
there was some good character
development in it it was it's kind of
like The Avengers it's the same universe
but it's very much like let's combine
the action and the drama and give
something with a little more head so I
my opinion it edged out Avengers a
little for me but yeah I mean it's it's
hard for me to say like it's just it
feels like two different movie I mean I
think I'm saying Avengers sake I loved
Avengers I say I like Avengers a little
bit more sort of because it did feel it
felt a little bit more contained which
even though I know is whatever lead to a
major to himself but and I do like
movies like that just a touch more but
I'm still with you that doesn't mean
this is by any means a bad movie or far
less or anything it's a different kind
of movie and it may respect it is strong
but the fact that we can have this
conversation and you have to think about
it for a second yeah it's the spray of
that's pretty amazing anything can you
can you imagine telling your you know 10
year old self like 20 something years
ago and being like oh ya know in the
future there will be a really good
Captain America movie like the think
back to you they can but here's your
we've in our view of a nostalgic real
fantastic or the Punisher those crappy
80's early 90's films like I still have
made a good Punisher
and now they have it but like when you
think about what Marvel was what kind of
oil we've definitely yeah I'm a boo-boo
bees were and I mean all credit to DC
for resurrecting it with Tim Burton's
Batman and and at least keeping it alive
with you know Superman but man when it
came to Marvel that decade was a desert
ya know and it's nice it's like what
which way things bear the Captain
America one or the Avengers want it but
yeah but okay my sink there's a wait a
minute Avengers like oh yeah they got
Iron Man and Hulk and Thor they all have
their own movies by the way uh Oh judge
myself on it Oh Captain America by be
sending her back wait you mean kind of a
second-tier ish character everyone's got
as he goes in and out of popularity but
I mean an icon but you know he's no
Batman he's no Superman when it comes to
popularity gets two movies out of like
20 Marvel movies like I want to believe
you why it is funny it's again it's
interesting just how it's like we're at
a Golden Age of comic book movies I'm
yeah I'm good I mean cuz there are some
pretty damn bad ones and there is a
fatigue I get from sitting through the
really bad ones but I think we're gonna
look back 20 years ago me like man
remember when comic book movies just
ruled the earth
ya know they're like the thing now right
now I think like and whatever late
eighties deals like stand-up comics rule
the earth and then like early 2000s it
was like fantasy and now it's like the
comic book well like the eighties
there's a lot of sci-fi sci-fi yes I
yeah but now it's yeah comic books are
you think this film just really hammers
in how really behind the eight-ball DC
and Warner Brothers are well yeah I mean
like I'm like looking at this like okay
so your your mid-level you know good
character but you're kind of second to
your character gets whether they just
made probably one of the best comic book
movies since Avengers since
Dark Knight you know they already have
all of this set up Marvel has set
everything up and we're we know in the
DC Universe we may we're gonna get a
Batman vs. Superman movie oh where else
got and the side Wonder Woman is gonna
be in there
Greenland's what a great movie for
diversity this one is for then this is
really ironic for a movie that's about
the whitest of white superheroes like
Wonder Bread Boy Scout Captain America
we've got Falcon
we've got Nick Fury we've got Black
Widow coming completely into row and she
carries like I could hunk of wait until
she gets her own movie I hear ya doing a
movie with her and I'm excited I really
want to see how that's gonna turn all
these great diverse characters and yeah
over at DC it's like well we make it
wonder bomb in a cameo in Batman vs
Superman or something that we're set up
for the Justice League movie it'll
happen eventually it'll and I'm like
guys you're so far behind
you used to be ahead of the game what
happened well and they are thing to frog
utilize things and we're probably going
on too long here but the other thing too
with this Marvel Universe and something
you know you can't yelling at DC and I
guess kind of rightfully self at the
same time
well Marvel is done here what they have
put together I mean really has never
quite been done before on this grander
scale to have movies and shows and
movies combining other movies all linked
up all have to be executed well enough
yeah I moved it out my brain was you can
still kind of slide through it but yeah
like you you even want to see the crab
films just to see what the end credits
scene is you know just what the to be
continued you know it's actually we're
returning to movie serials but they're
talking the same thing this one else
like it's just like on an item lash
Gordon yeah this is totally Flash Gordon
the 30s movie serials done with 200
million dollars kind of like maybe what
Star Wars would have been and you told
20 vered 20 separate stories with it you
know but how am I to know is it well we
might know that yes he's got that and
Marvel oh my god they're going to is me
have us now
and let me just say very person level
what a fine fine company it is just to
just have to know what Oh kick your ass
it was mostly positive yeah everyone
thinks I was like a tie and now it all -
the day we do give it after maker yeah
we shot it and edited one and people get
upset at me and I'm like or you hate DC
in the hey Madison
I don't hate DC I actually feel what I'm
upset because I enjoy competition that I
get people are just like which can be
little Marvel vs. DC we have should
because competition is what makes you
want to strive to be better than the
other guy and keep competing and I just
want DC and Warner Brothers to just do
better
I like Superman I like them and Sandman
was one of my favorite comic book series
of all time we'll grab a novel but so
they're just playing catch-up get with
it
so um yeah final some up it's it's a
good action flick it's got good actually
it's got a good character uh good
supporting characters uh in it as well
um it is sort of a transition to the
next movie even the very last scene
indicates it's there's like three or
four trains again I will say this so I
think it does work well enough on its
own which is one of the things are
anyway look good yeah I mean it tells
look it does tell ya there's side things
that are like swept you have to see the
movie both yeah there's a full story arc
though in this one yeah it doesn't it
doesn't quite just feel like full filler
it's like you feel these characters have
discovered something but come with your
it's a movie it's still a movie yeah you
know it's not just the middle you know
it's like an Empire Strikes Back
yeah it's sort of plan Empire Strikes
really was continuing a story but yeah
it's it's a decent film and it's good
actually if you're just looking for a
good popcorn movie with some decent
character building and and good stuff in
it uh it's a good movie to check out so
and closing thoughts
blows Iron Man to those Thor movies Man
of Steel everything else out of the
waters free yeah
Iron Man 3 like make more like these yes
all I can say and why are you sitting
here watching this go see it again you
in the cab make it hip I just did that